et puis cet incendie au coeur des
interrogations le restaurant parisien la
rotonde a été détruit cette nuit par les
flammes
la roue tourne a lieu prisé par le chef
de l'état on souvient c'est là bas qu'il
avait fêté sa victoire au premier tour
des présidentielles est la piste
privilégiée est celle de l'acte
volontaire selon une source proche de
l'enquêté à la sûreté territoriale de
paris est chargée du dossier la réaction
du cogérant de cette brasserie
il est abattu par les conséquences de
l'incendié écoutez le cette nuit à 5h05
j'ai été réveillé par le service de
vidéosurveillance que nous avons la
norme parce qu'il y avait une intrusion
dans l'établissement et donc ils m'ont
appelé ils m'ont réveillé et monde il ya
également un incendie et donc voilà je
me suis levé du coup je me suis levé je
suis venu sur place et les pompiers
étaient déjà là et on a constaté qu' il
y avait une vitre qui avait été cassée
et qu'ils avaient mis le feu et que le
feu il avait mis le feu à la console en
droit ici et les pompiers sont arrivés
vite et voilà comment ça s'est passé
c'est arrivé entre 4h30 et 5h du matin
on n'a pas une idée de qui que ce soit
on avait reçu plusieurs fois des menaces
verbales et puis mais on se doute quand
même que c'est criminel parce qu'il ya
une vie qui a été cassé
donc c'est pas un accident électrique
une enquête est en cours mais je pense
qu'elle confirmera ce que j'ai dit on
est abattu on est triste pour moi c'est
un acte lâche parce que voilà c'est fait
la nuit à personne sait pas qui c'est
qu'a fait ça j'espère que la police doit
les retrouver mais on est tous abattu il
ya 40 personnes qui travaillent ici à
peu près un peu plus et voilà ces
personnes vont se retrouver au chômage
[Musique]